a super heroic decapitation while the
new entry in the DC extended Universe
has plenty of action-packed moments and
nods to other films there is one
mind-blowing reason why moviegoers
should stick around for the Black Adam
mid credit scene keep watching to find
out but beware spoilers ahead the highly
anticipated film tells the story of a
child named harout who is enslaved in
ancient conduct and rallies to overthrow
the country's oppressive ruler on cot
his efforts lead him to the Council of
wizards first introduced in Shazam like
Billy Batson herroot is granted his
powers by the council fast forward five
thousand years and Black Adam who is
known for most of the film as teth Adam
is reawakened by Adriana Tomas when her
team is ambushed by intergang a military
force that has taken control of kondok
but this teth Adam is not the hero she's
heard about and she discovers that the
current teth Adam is actually heroot's
father who heroot gave his powers to
right before his sudden death she
quickly learns about his auntie her zero
ways when he kills many of his foes
during the inter-gang attack Adriana and
her son Amman work to teach him how to
seek Justice without killing others the
film is a treat for DC fans who have
eagerly awaited the big screen arrival
of Black Adam Hawkman Dr Fate cyclone
and Adam Smasher but there is one big
name that many fans did not see coming
in this particular film Henry Cavill
makes a triumphant return as Superman in
the mid-credits scene of Black Adam
while it's a big moment for the dceu the
scene and Cavill didn't come into the
picture until production was well
underway during the Hollywood reporters
behind the screen podcast Black Adam
cinematographer Lawrence Schurz said
cavil was not always attached to the
film due to tough negotiations behind
the scenes but that didn't stop them
from making the most of their last day
of filming additional photography sure
said that director Joe mccolette Sarah
quickly filmed Dwayne Johnson's portion
of the scene using a throne room set
that was already set up a body double
filled in for Cavill making sure to
Showcase that iconic logo without
revealing the actor's face effectively a
headlight Superman the scene without
Cavill was included in test screenings
and the audience's reaction helped sure
realize they were on the right track he
said I went to a test screening in which
they did the version without his head
and it played gangbusters then it was
like now we got to get Henry while the
Final Cut of the scene with Henry Cavill
definitely pays off it was an uphill
climb to get the current Man of Steel
and Black Adam Dwayne Johnson reportedly
pushed for Cavill to join the film even
going to the leaders of Warner Brothers
film after former DC films president
Walter Hamato rejected the idea the
conversation between Johnson Michael
Deluca and Pamela Abdi ultimately gave
them the green light to add Cavill
producer Hiram Garcia told the rep that
he Johnson and cavill's manager Danny
Garcia worked very hard to make that
on-screen moment a reality he said it
was just Relentless I'm sure borderline
extremely annoying for some of our
partners but we knew what the fans
wanted we knew what we wanted and we
would just not stop because we really
wanted to deliver what we felt the whole
world wanted and what we felt was the
proper moment for the character of Black
Adam arriving in the c universe cavill's
Cameo may be just the beginning of
bringing Superman and Cavill back into
the DC fold in a recent interview with
Cinema Blend Johnson said the Return of
Superman is the whole point of Black
Adam while Hiram Garcia cannot yet
confirm whether or not cavil has signed
on for more movies in the dceu he does
note that Cavill wanted to come back for
Black Adam adding that there may be some
potential projects in the works
thank you